So far, we have described how data store uses
indexes to execute queries. Now is the time to look
at some query restrictions that exist. As you know
by now, data store was designed to be massively scalable.
Therefore the performance of queries should only depend on
the size of the result set, in other words the
amount of data returned in the query and not
on the overall amount of data stored in data storage.
To meet this objective, data store always uses the
indexes to find the matching data. And this leads
to two restrictions you should be aware of when
you design your applications. The first one is an inequality
filter can be applied to at most one property
within the query. The following filter is not valid
because we are applying an inequality filter for two
different properties. The second rule is that a property with
an equality filter must be sorted first. The
following query is for example not valid. Since the
property max attendees is used with an inequality filter,
it must be the first property after Sort By,
not name. The best way to avoid these
restrictions is to think and plan which queries you
need during the design phase. That way, you can
design around them. So now we'll do an exercise
where you will explore these query restrictions.